marching to lutherat a small village
that has become a symbol for the fight
against global warming
more protesters than both activists and
police had expected came to the remote
side of one of Germany's largest lake
night of brown coal mines in the
country's most industrialized region
visitors out here we're here because we
know it isn't over yet with the eviction
it's a global fight we have to build
policies that are sustainable so we keep
going
is being demolished after a camp of
hundreds of climate activists had been
affected in the past few days if showing
clearly today that the changes will not
come from the people in power from
governments from corporations from the
so-called leaders no the real leaders
are here it is the people who are
sitting in tree houses and those who
have been defending list for example for
years now shame on the Energy company
rwe and on the German government that
were the words of Greta tunberg who
traveled from Sweden to this muddy field
near the village of luxurat the village
that has been evicted by police in the
last couple of days to make way for this
brown Coal Mine which is very near more
than 1500 bullies from around the
country were sent to Lutheran to prevent
it from being occupied by activists
again
[Music]
several were injured during these
clashes
police also use water cannons and horses
to keep protesters away
while the activists have lost lucerat as
an international climate protest site
they say they will continue to Rally
against the expansion of the gas Viola
mine stop fasting Al Jazeera near
lutzerat